so what what I'll try to do is retrace
our steps a little bit and look forward
and then say a few words about the topic
at 10 which is faith in reconciliation
and then I'm going to hand it to mr.
Blair for the rest of the of the class
so what we've done in this in this
course is we've looked first at the
globalization first session a bit about
history or prehistory of it and then we
had a session that looked at the perils
and the promise promise and the peril of
globalization processes we've also look
at the world of fades and the world of
fates that are how the world of fates is
impacted is that a verb what is deemed
it's not a very good one how the world
of aid is what impact does a
globalization have on world of faiths we
talked about secularism possible
connection between secularization and
globalization and spent quite a bit of
time on transformation of fades in their
transformation of faiths as a result of
progressing globalization processes
we've also looked at in the last session
of possible influence faiths on
globalization processes themselves and
including and this was a point that Jose
Casanova has emphasized including faiths
as agents of globalization especially if
you extend the definition of
globalization or the look at the
phenomenon of globalization and reaching
way back into the into the head then you
can see how faiths or in nyon chandras
phrase preachers were one of the agents
of globalization so and this was a kind
of a general survey of the intersection
of these two forces fades and
globalization and what we've also done
is we've isolated two fundamental issues
that run
through the course and this was on the
one hand a question of the role of
faiths in the conflicts in the world
globalization's bringing globalization
bringing people together making them
interdependent creating a world of
diversity and pluralism in faiths often
stable on identities and sometimes in
very contrasting and therefore also
conflictual kinds of ways we've also
looked at the potential of eight and
asked about the potential of a to
humanize globalization processes and
we've identified that at the level
humanization both at the level of
processes for instance fairness issue of
fairness how important that is and
contributions that fate might have in
nurturing the virtue of fairness as well
as a kind of ends that people or goals
that people pursue ultimate goals that
people pursue within the processes of
globalization we talked about the self
the social relations and the good the
defined religions that defined cultures
and that can be seen as goals that are
pursued within the processes of
globalization so now we come from this
nexus of issues of faith and
globalization in more general terms to
specific issues so this is a kind of
watershed in our course will first look
at question of violence and
reconciliation then we have sessions on
business basically politics and in
culture now as it turns out we have a
session on reconciliation before we have
a session on violence and religion in
violence that that isn't quite the
logical order that you would that you
would expect but but some of it was
conditioned by by a set of circumstances
where we had planned for the classes you
may recall possibly to visit go to
Washington DC to a conference of the
common about the common word you have
studied that case as a case study the
idea was for you to travel
there to experience it first firsthand
alas it was a closed conference and it
would not have been worth your while to
sit at the door outside not being able
to sit in by that time we've already
organized everything including mr.
Blair's visit here so we couldn't quite
reverse a reverse this but common word
is a very good example of of a ways in
which faith can be understood as serving
the the process of reconciliation and
what's significant for me let me
underline in the in the common word
document is that the document whose main
thesis is right you will recall that
Muslims and Christians what binds them
is not just belief in common God in one
God but also commitment to worship God
and also to love to love neighbor to
love God and to love to love neighbor
now what's what's interesting here is
that commonalities significant
commonalities are affirmed without
denying the differences differences are
clearly preserved but there is an
indication of a significant overlap in
in core convictions of these two
tradition and obviously both of these
traditions get the idea of love of
neighbor love of God and love of
neighbor from Judaism and also that
communities are something that touches
what is genuinely at the heart of these
faiths because you can imagine how some
third party might find it convenient to
find convergences between faith and then
pull things together so as to create
something artificially as overlapping
right and then obviously it will become
the productive because nobody would be
embracing that particular faith what's
interesting here is that at least that's
the claim that the commonality is
touched what each of these faiths deep
down embrace as part of genuinely their
own and also I think what is significant
is that what's common
is love of God and love of neighbor now
it could be nasty right if the common
thing was something something rather
negative in regards to exclusivity or
something of that something of that sort
so a commonality that an overlap is a
love of God and love of the neighbor
which takes us i think to an important
aspect of our discussion here and namely
that in discussion about faith and
reconciliation and violence it is really
significant to look at the concrete
shapes of faith you can just say faith
but you have to look at the content of
fades and many of the fates Judaism
Christianity and Islam certainly have
elements in their traditions which do
not seem particularly conducive to the
work of a reconciliation right and so
it's significant to look at a particular
configuration of these elements of faith
that are genuinely belong to faith
themselves and are also conducive to
reconciliation I have invoked a few
times the phrase from David Martin about
fades having a repertoire and you can
from which then depending on
circumstances depending on historical
developments there draw draw or some
things they leave aside some things are
foreground and other things are back
rounded and I think that's very
important for us to keep in mind that
fates are dynamic entities and therefore
that we can have genuine embrace of
faith even if you can find in those
fades also elements that are counter to
reconciliation process is counter to to
peace nonetheless people of a conceal
feel themselves as embracing generally
their own faith and promoting at the
heart of it that which serves
reconciliation processes there are a
number of such things at least I can
speak for for various faiths primarily
for Christianity which I know the best
for instance the
that were important in common word war
certainly dignity of each human person
each human person is a creature of God
therefore that which often happens in
conflicts namely that you seek to
dehumanize the other just about in all
the conflicts serious conflicts that I
know the process of dehumanization
precedes a serious deployment of
violence right you are vermin York
encroaches you or whatever that is
you're subhuman and because yours read
as subhuman therefore we can exterminate
you therefore we can without moral
compunction exercise violence over you
so was in Rhonda's so it was in former
Yugoslavia certainly so it was in the
Nazi Germany so very important element
in the common word many other faiths is
the sense of common human dignity and
therefore requirement of the respect of
the humanity of the other and what I
think also interesting and important the
common word that beyond a sense of a
respect for the humanity there goes also
the idea of care for the other that is
the idea of the love of the neighbor
that is so central for both of these
faiths in the context of conflict that
is often of incredible importance
because you have to somehow care not
just about yourself but also about the
other and about the relationship with
the other for reconciliation to get
going at least that's what fades would
like to to think key element certainly
in the Christian tradition and some of
it you've read also in your readings was
a question of forgiveness in
reconciliation processes and that too is
ultimately tied with the care for the
other as other person without care for
the other as other reconciliation
forgiveness cannot get going one other
element and it's here i will i will
close
the element that is really important
than Scott Appleby emphasizes this and
this is the question of hope and often
in the situations of conflict the
question is how do you sustain a hope in
the long haul but everything seems to be
working against you I'm sure Mr Blair
will will will confirm this insecure in
the context of Ireland situation of
Ireland very often when I went there the
question was well how do we not lose
hope you feel like you were making these
risks going toward reconciliation and
every time you make a step it kind of
bounces back at you in so many situation
this is exactly what it is and
sustaining of hope is often what
religious traditions bring to the
reconciliation process I think I'm going
to stop right here and invite mr. Blair
to the podium